now to have your designs or products
make it into the grammy gifting suite it
is a huge honor so this year's grammys
have been signed by mcfly
the full name is mugsy mcfly
so get the mixed fly you gotta have the
new fly in there so let's start off with
just telling us the inspiration behind
your name and what it means
well it's kind of two parts so mcfly is
an acronym many can't fly like you and
it's also a testament to back to the
future um that's my favorite movie back
to future two honestly because you know
that was more future based that was my
favorite movie um and it's kind of
testament to me wanting to be timeless
so that's the mixed fly part and muggy
um is a homage to um the basketball
player monkey bugs he was five three the
shortest basketball player ever
professional basketball player ever yeah
and at the time
i stand six one and a half now i was
like 411 in high school playing ball so
the main kind of stuck mugsy's from
uptown bronx new york where growing up
he couldn't afford the best clothes but
he did have access to the best
customization but there was like a
sports store like a couple blocks away
from where i live and i used to buy
clothes i used to buy sneakers but i
couldn't get the clothing i want so i
would go to them and try to customize
things like they made stuff so i was
like oh i know what to eye let me see
the size and flawlessness to match these
news and the colors so i started
creating fast forward he started
creating and modeling for other brands
until he realized it was time to leave
his own mark on the world and the whole
name is summer mcfly because
anything i do has my signature on it now
his designs are based on trend they're
based on life i have a lot of camo stuff
um my mom was active duty military my
whole time in college so i i grew up
camera even though everybody loves
camouflage but i lived it it was real
and the brand evolves with his
experiences experiences like the
pandemic so signed by mcfly is keeping
you fly but comfortable as of right now
i would say i'm really
um
athleisure
cozy
comfortable sporty so you know i have
stuff for girls that they can work out
in and i have something else that they
could go on vacation or they could go to
the club speaking my language and on top
of all of that he's inspiring i try to
move on purpose and i feel like you know
i don't have a fashion background i
didn't want to school for fashion so i
want to be able to show that kid out
there that likes clothes that you could
actually be in a field
and do something you actually honestly
love i want to wake up and be excited to
go have this interview or make some
clothes or have a fashion show or have a
pop-up shop or participate in some big
big events you know why not big big
events like the grammys where his
trucker hats will be part of the
official 2022 gift bags added value to
like you know all the work i did to just
be in the same sentence as these stars
just
wow like
wow i'm here i'm not physically there
but i am physically they're part of me
leaving his signature on the culture for
the culture
influenced by the culture even me doing
the truck act it's a very it's paying
homage to pharrell because you know
perella with neptunes and he's all the
truck hats and little videos and that
was the first i'm not gonna lie the
first like urban black man i think he
wear a truck in a fashionable way
besides an actual trucker like hip-hop
is fascinating
[Music]
hip-hop is fashion okay you did a great
job with that thank you i think that was
a crazy fashion show too that was so
good they're having fun today i know
fashion and music you can't go wrong
with that you can get muggy's trucker
hat yourself at signbymcfly.com and rock
it before all the grammy stars do you
know set the train yourself all right so
still to come on las vegas now